MICHELLE CHEUNG: Thanks everyone
for attending our topic.
Today, we're going to be
talking about Cyanogen themes,
your phone your canvas.
So we have three speakers
here today, obviously.
So I'm Michelle, the senior
product manager for themes.
Before that, I actually
was working at Xiaomi,
also working a
bit around themes,
and helping the
company expand abroad.
We have Clark, who officially
has been hacking on Android
since the release of the G1.
Prior to Cyanogen, he
worked on Chameleon OS,
which is a Cyanogen
mod based ROM,
which supports the MIUI themes.
Unofficially, he is
our theme wizard.
And then we have Dave,
who is the product
designer in our team.
And prior to that, he
was working in kovdev.
Unofficially, he's actually
our in-house theme design guru.
And one we haven't added.
We have, over there, Andy.
He's one of the original
members of themes.
He works on our theme store
and a lot of service stuff.
But he actually built
out the theme store too.
So yeah, he's right over there.
OK.
So we have one of the
most awesome teams.
But we're here today
to talk about themes
and personalisation.
So we're going to
talk about, what
are themes, how themes
work, designing themes,
and we're going to preview
one of our next big things
we've been working on.
So what are themes?
At Cyanogen, we
believe you should
be able to make your phone
as unique as you are.
After all, everyone's different.
Everyone has their own
style, their own passions,
their own interests.
So theme was the
solution to this.
It allows the end user
to easily change the look
and feel of their device.
You have the ability
to change out
the lock screen, boot animation,
icons, fonts, ringtones.
Pretty much anything,
you name it.
So we actually take
themes quite seriously,
and we're glad the media
also recognizes it as well.
I'm going to talk a little bit
more about the theme products.
So for the end users, we have
Theme Store, Theme Chooser,
and App Themer.
For developers, we
have the Theme Studio.
The Theme Store houses
Cyanogen themes.
It streamlines the
discovery process
and optimizes search results
so that you can easily
search just icons, controls,
wallpapers, and fonts.
All of the content
in the store is all
created by the community.
The Theme Store offers users a
deeper level of customization.
So users can select a theme,
separate it into components,
then swap the components
with another theme.
So like mix and
match, so to speak.
This allows the users to
create endless combinations
of themes that is completely
unique to the individual.
Then we have App Themer,
which takes it even further.
So this allows the end user
to just customize one app
and the rest of the device
remains in its original theme.
Lastly, we have
the Theme Studio.
It's a platform where
theme developers
can upload their
theme to the store,
and allows them to
track the downloads
and manage their themes.
So the products I just
talked about-- this
is like a framework
that ties everything in.
So it starts off,
if you can see here,
on the Theme Studio end, where
the theme developers upload
their theme.
Then it gets published
onto the Theme Store
where then it gets
reflected by the end user,
and then it gets applied.
And Clark will talk
a little bit more
specifically in
detail about that.
So the Theme Store,
actually, we've
launched in about a little
less than a year ago.
And I want to share with
you some general statistics.
Majority of the themes right
now we have are all paid.
So about 85% are paid
and 15% are free.
It's all community driven and we
have about a 5.5% weekly growth
rate.
So which components do
users like to customize?
We have a lot of different
components, and a lot of people
actually tend to
think wallpapers
might be the most often that
people like to customize.
But surprisingly, it's actually
boot animation and fonts--
I mean, fonts is actually
the most popular,
followed by icons, and
then it's boot animation.
OK.
Now I'll pass it to Clark
to explain how themes work.
CLARK SCHEFF: Guys hear me OK?
All right.
So being an engineer, I like
to know how things work.
Any engineers out
here right now?
Software engineers?
Any of you guys?
All right, well
we've got a couple.
So hopefully you guys, I'm
here to at least explain
a little bit how themes works on
the backside in our framework.
So let's get started.
How exactly does the theme work?
When you actually
are using a theme,
what happens in the backend
that actually makes it change
the visual look and feel?
Well, as my boy Shy would say?
It's magic.
While I would love to
say this, because that
would be the easy way out,
I'm not going to do that.
So let's take a look
at it a little bit.
So we leverage a thing
called the Runtime Resource
Overlay, or RRO for short.
This was something introduced
by Sony a couple years ago,
and it's actually
in AOSP right now.
So Andy Mast-- actually, I'm
going to put him on the spot
again.
This guy started the foundation
before I started here.
So he actually started
working on the RRO
before I ever had a chance.
But we leveraged something
that's already in AOSP.
It made sense, right?
We don't want to
reinvent the wheel.
So we took that and went
a little step further
to make it work with
our theme engine.
So what does RRO do?
Well, it replaces resources
at runtime, hence the name.
It does that by
mapping resources
from a theme to the application.
So whenever we want to get a
resource from an application,
it'll be find the themed version
and give that back to us.
And so this magic is
really happening down
at the native layer,
where doing this
is in the order of microseconds.
So we can fetch these themes
resources really quick,
so we don't see an
impact to the user.
To understand what's
going on here,
we have to have a
little background
on what resources are.
So what are resources
in an application?
They're not these
resources, sorry.
Hit the wrong slide.
What they are--
resources are just
assets the application
can access.
Besides the code,
it's got access
to things like what
are called drawables.
These can be bitmaps, they
can be vector drawables, which
were introduced in lollipop.
They can be shapes.
Colored drawables.
There's a plethora
of drawables that are
accessible to an application.
And themes can also
interchange these drawables.
So it could be a
lot more flexible.
If a drawable was a
bitmap, we can turn it
into a vector drawable.
We can turn into an
animated drawable.
So it becomes something much
more than it originally was.
There's layouts.
Layouts define the UI
for the application.
So this tells
where the views are
in the layout, where buttons
are, and stuff like that.
There's XML, which is usually
just generic XML that's
specific to the application.
There's no set format for it.
It usually can define certain
information, maybe stays
or configs and stuff like that,
specific to an application.
And then some of the
meat and potatoes
is in an area called values.
These are XML, which define
various types of values
like arrays, colors,
dimensions that
can be used for padding, text
sizes, and stuff like that.
The strings, the text that
you see on your buttons
and in the UI is usually defined
in this XML values, as well
as styles.
Now styles is--
basically think of it
as a collection
of attributes that
determine how an application
looks, or a UI element looks.
So we've got this
thing called a bag that
takes all these attributes,
puts them together,
and then displays
those to the user.
So while we have access
to all these resources,
there's a few that we
do not allow to theme.
And there's good
reason for that.
Layouts we don't allow to
theme, because applications
update all the time.
And if an application
gets updated,
and they add a new view, or
they change their layout--
if we theme that,
they're going to now try
to get that part of
the UI that's not there
now because it's been themed.
The app's going to crash.
So it looks bad.
And usually the user doesn't
see the theme as the culprit,
they see the app as the culprit.
So we don't want
application developers
to be blamed for stuff that our
theme engine could be doing.
So that's off limits.
XML just doesn't make
sense because that's
specific to the application,
so there's no need to do that.
Arrays.
Arrays are usually a
collection of values,
and those values can be
other resources like color.
So those can be
themed elsewhere,
so we don't touch arrays.
We don't touch
things like booleans
because booleans can change
values true or false.
And a theme could
potentially enable something
the developer didn't want
to enable because they
were using a boolean value.
And then strings.
Strings, we shouldn't be
changing text anyways.
A theme could be malicious, and
maybe phish, and change text,
and they change
the icon of an app,
and now they change the text to
make it look like a banking app
or something like that.
And then there's
the whole aspect
of translations and locales.
I mean, if your
theme is stringed,
you're basically going
to have to provide all
the translations for it too.
It's poor user experience.
So those types of
things are off-limits.
So now that we understand
what resources are,
there's a couple of ways
that an application actually
accesses the resources.
One of those is via XML.
So here I've got an
example-- this is actually
a vector drawable that was
introduced in Lollipop.
This one happens to be of
our CyanogenMod mascot, Sid.
And if you look here in the red,
there's a reference here called
@color/cyan.
That's a color we defined
elsewhere in our application.
It's one those resources.
And so now, whenever
this icon is drawn,
it's going to fetch
that color and it's
going to be drawn in that.
Now a theme could now
change that color,
and so Sid could
be instead of cyan,
he's now purple, or maybe pink.
Depends on what themer wants.
The other way we can access
resources is via code.
So an application
developer might want
to access certain resources.
So they can do that.
One important thing is a need
to import this R. Java class.
To let Java know what
classes and stuff you're
going to be using in your
code, you have to import it.
This is a specific classic that
gets generated at build time
for the developer.
So a lot of this is
extracted to them,
they don't really see what's
going on under the hood.
So I'm actually going to
provide a little details
for that for you.
But in this case,
we're trying to get
a string and a
drawable via code,
and we're accessing
them using that R.class.
And for strings,
we're using R.string,
and for drawables,
we're using R.drawable.
So it's an easy way to get
those resources, both in XML
and to the application in code.
So now we're going to
talk about resource IDs.
And we did have a problem
here earlier getting access,
but Sid is helping us
out, so we've got our ID
and we can get past this now.
So resource IDs.
This is the meat and potatoes
of how resources are provided
to an application at runtime.
Now, as I mentioned,
these resource IDs
are generated at build time
from a tool called AAPT.
And that's Android
Asset Packaging Tool.
This tool will look
at your resources,
generate the R.Java for you so
you can access that via code,
and it also creates this thing
called a resource table that
has all those IDS
stored in a format
that it can quickly
access at runtime.
So it's a very efficient system.
The resource IDs are
unique to the application,
but they're not
always the same IDs
across different applications.
It can vary.
So resource ID, it's
just an integer.
It's a value that
tells the system
a few bits of information.
The first one on the
left is the Package ID.
Now Android's got this concept
of packages for resources.
Every application gets the
Android framework resources,
which is package ID 0x01.
Application, third party
apps, end up getting 0x7f,
which is at the bottom
of the spectrum.
And then everything in
between there's libraries,
and other types
of resources that
can be loaded in with their own
resource ID that get tagged on.
So you got a package ID
that tells the system, OK,
which group am I going to
grab this resource from?
Now the next value
is a resource type.
This is a value that was
generated runtime as well that
says, OK, it's a drawable,
it's an integer, it's a string,
it's whatever.
This number tells it exactly
where to go in this table.
And then last, once it's found
that area where those types
are, it's got an entry index.
And that just tells it
really quickly where
to go in memory to fetch
that resource for you.
So using these three
values, it can quickly
grab a resource at
runtime and bring it
right back to the
application to be used,
whether it's in layouts, code.
We've got resource IDs.
We've got resources.
Now how do we get the theme
to work with all this, right?
So there's a tool called IDMAP.
This is built in
with Android system.
It's a binary that runs
when the app's installed,
when the theme's installed.
And basically what it does,
is it creates a mapping
from the application
to resources that
map it to that one in a theme.
So it's using
those resource IDs,
it basically goes
through the theme
looks at all the different
resources it has,
and first it looks at the type.
The type needs to match.
So a drawable needs to
match to a drawable,
a string to a string, so forth.
You can't mix and match.
You can't have a dimension
being mapped to a color.
So that's the first constraint.
The second one, is the name of
those resources have to match.
So before, you saw in my
example I had my app icon,
and stuff like that.
So those names need to match.
And once it finds that matching
between those two values,
it'll say, OK, the application's
resource ID is this,
the theme's resource ID is this.
So now it knows that
whenever I ask for this guy,
it can just point
directly to this one
and fetch that resource instead
of the original application.
And the way this is stored,
just like the resource table,
it's in a efficient structure
where we can quickly
grab these mappings and fetch
the resource as if it was never
themed.
I mean, it's really quick.
So how's this work once
we've got all this in place?
Our application is
going to say, hey,
I want to get this
drawable called app_icon.
OK, so we ask the system, hey,
can you fetch me this drawable?
So it goes down, and there's a
thing called an asset manager,
and it will actually try to
grab that resource for you.
It's taken that ID that
we've provided to it,
it's going to say, OK,
which package is it in?
It's in 0x7f, all right.
We're going to look it up.
We find the resource,
but we see that it's
got an ID mapped to it.
So what do we do?
Well, we're now going to point
to the themes resource table.
And ultimately,
the system's going
to return the themed resource.
So even though we were asking
for this app_icon, what
we get back is the
themed version, which
happens to be this foo.png.
So we've got
everything in place,
we've got these resources
being mapped and stuff.
So what's it look like
once we start doing this?
On the left here, we've
got the quick setting tiles
from Lollipop.
This is what everybody's
used to seeing.
Like an AOSP, this is the
standard look and feel.
But let's apply one theme.
So we've got the same thing.
We still got our
quick setting tiles.
Nothing changed there.
But now we've got
some different look.
We've got some different colors,
some different iconography.
Even some of the dimensions
can change within there, just
to give it a better
different look
and feel for that
particular user.
And if we do it one
more time, once again,
everything's still
laid out the same way,
but we get a visually
different look.
So if the demo gods are
going to play nicely with me,
I'm going to actually
just show you
guys real time a
couple theme changes.
So you can just see that
we are doing this runtime,
and it's really quick.
Sorry.
You see that for the most part.
So I'm going to go from
our settings application,
we can go right to
our theme chooser.
And like Michelle said, we
can mix and match themes.
So we don't have to
apply a theme whole sale.
So right now, here's what
my Status Bar looks like
and the Quick Settings Drawer.
So I'm just going to
change my system UI.
I'm going to go to one of our
other themes here called HEXO.
I'm just going to hit Apply.
And now I've got a different
look and feel there.
Another cool thing that
I love to play with,
is our App Themer.
So, I'm going to
use this instead.
We're in Settings.
I just want to
change settings, I
don't want to change
anything else.
And this is where App Themer
is really awesome for that.
Now that I'm in Settings, I
can click on this little fab
up here, and I get a button.
So let's go back to System.
So there you see, we're right
back at the system theme,
just like that runtime.
Don't like that?
Here's our new ZUK, Z-1 theme.
So again, it's settings,
but visually, it's
slightly different.
You can see that we can
change a lot of the elements
to give you a look and feel.
But we're not
reorganizing stuff.
Because like I said,
we don't change layout.
So the user's still going to
be comfortable with the UI.
They just get a
different look and feel.
They make it their own.
And that's what
themes is all about.
So now that we see how
themes works, and we
know how to apply theme
and see how it goes,
Kover here is going to let you
guys know how to make a theme
and actually get it published.
DAVE KOVER: All right.
So Clark just told you about
how themes actually work,
and now we're going to talk
about how to design themes.
So what goes into a theme?
We have nine
different components
that you're able to include
inside a theme on Cyanogen.
So we have lock screen, boot
animation, notifications,
ringtones, alarms,
fonts, overlays, icons,
and wallpapers.
Some of those are really simple
swaps, where it's one-to-one.
So something like
the lock screen.
Right now, we currently allow
you to change the wallpaper
on a lock screen.
So it's as simple as including a
new wallpaper within the theme,
and when the user
applies the theme,
you'll have that wallpaper.
That same type of
one-to-one swap
happens with the boot
animation, notification sound,
ringtone sound, alarms.
Fonts, it can a little fun.
So you can include a
completely different font
and have that work
throughout the system.
But the cool thing
about fonts now
is that you can actually
change the font per weight.
So for your bold
characters you might want
to have like a different font?
You can do that.
You can include a font and
have that one called out
specifically.
Maybe for italics, you want
to get a nice script font?
You could have that too.
So you could have
that kind of diversity
within the system that will
work throughout the entirety.
So if an app says, hey, I
want this italic weight,
your font will be
provided there.
So that's a really cool
thing that we offer.
Of all of these
components, the ones
that have the biggest
visual impact for users
are the overlays, the
icons, and the wallpapers.
So wallpapers, pretty simple
just like the lock screen.
If you include a wallpaper
within your theme,
it will work.
And actually, in our latest
12.1 release of CyanogenOS,
you can actually include
multiple wallpapers now
that a user will be able to
choose through in the Theme
Chooser that we saw earlier.
So let's talk about icons.
Now we all know
that's how we have
to interact with the
applications on our device.
If you want to get into Twitter,
you got to click that icon.
You want to get into
Facebook, you click the icon.
So that's a really big piece
of the visual landscape
when a user is interacting
on your device.
So with themes, you can actually
create unique icon sets that
work to match the
rest of the look
and feel that you're going,
and it's literally however
your imagination wants to be.
You can sit there
and go and create
just a whole different
look for each one,
and craft each one individually
to have that unique feel.
Now, let's say you don't want
to have to make 1,000 icons,
because that's
just a lot of work.
We offer the ability to compose
icons using a couple images,
and they'll be able to cover
an unlimited amount of icons.
So what you see
here is essentially
a sandwich of layers, right?
So we start at the bottom
with our little back plate
down here.
And what happens is you
can create this back plate.
And that's going to be
the first thing that
gets put into the canvas.
The next thing
you're going to see
would be the icon
that is provided
by the separate application.
So again like Facebook,
that's the icon from Facebook.
And then you can create
this masking layer.
So what a mask does is it
allows you to essentially create
a space that you
only want to show.
So if you wanted like a star,
you could create the star,
and the star inside is the
only bit that's going to show,
and then it's like you
scissor out the rest of it.
So from this one, it
looks like a fingerprint,
and that's what's
going to see, and I'll
show you that in a second.
And then on the top bit
would be an overlay.
So maybe you could do
something like you want
to create a diver's helmet.
So you could have the background
of the diver's helmet,
have that icon on
the center part,
and then you could actually
stamp the visor over it
and have this kind
of glassy look
that would cover the top of it,
giving this really cool look.
So you've made all those
layers, how do those work?
It's really, really simple.
Within the Icons
component, there's
a file called the App Filter.
And with just these
four lines right here,
we can create this system
where we have the icon back
plate that we made earlier, the
mask, as well as the overlay.
And then there's an
additional attribute
called the scale factor.
So you can actually scale
the stock icons up or down
to fit your needs.
So if you want them to be
up to fill out the space
that you're going to be
cutting out with the mask,
you can scale them up a
bit, like we've done here,
to make sure that
some of the edges
are still within the masking.
So what would that
look like on device?
Well, those layers that we
just had two slides ago,
this is what they look like
when they get composed together.
So for four images, you're able
to get a unique icon set that
will scale up to
however many apps
that a user has installed
on their device.
So it's just a really simple
way to get maximum coverage
and still have a themed
look on your device.
So we talked about icons.
Let's talk about overlays.
What's an overlay?
Well, so for every package
on the user's device,
there's going to
be resources that
are specific to that package.
So the theme is able
to break these down.
So you'll have your tree
structure, which will
have the assets, your overlays.
And then you're going
to be able to call out.
So every app has a package name.
So if it was the system UI,
which is your Pulldown Bars,
com.android.systemui.
And the same thing for the
Phone and for Settings.
Each one of those is going
to be a separate overlay
directory where you'll be able
to house the specific resources
for that one.
So we'll dive into that just
a little further right now.
But, I want to talk
about Common first.
Now Common is a unique
feature to our theme engine
that allows you to have
a central location that's
accessible to all of
the other application
overlays within the theme.
So if you're going to
be using a single color
throughout your theme, maybe
you want to make a blue theme.
What you can do is you
can include the blue color
within your Common overlay,
and then reference that value
in all of the other ones.
So instead of having to say,
like your hex code is whatever
it is, you don't have to put
that in every specific overlay.
You could put it
in one location,
and then tweak
that in the future.
So you've been working on
this for a couple weeks,
and you realize that blue
is just not saturated right.
So all you have to do is
update in the one location,
and it'll populate throughout
the rest of the theme,
and you won't have to
worry about it after that.
And again this common
folder is magical.
It works with everything--
drawables, styles, colors,
dimensions.
You could put anything that
the theme engine can cover,
you could put in there.
And that's going to allow you
to save space in your theme,
because you're not going
to have to duplicate
the same thing over and over.
So let's look at how an
overlay might get put together.
So here we have Settings.
So what are some of
the items on here?
Well, we have the ActionBar.
In particular, this
ActionBar is actually
going to be controlled by
a style within the app.
So we look here, and so a
big part of creating a theme
is actually having to
dive in and look how
each application is made up.
And luckily enough,
most of the source
is available right
on GitHub, so you
can go in and see how Settings
is made, how Dialer is made,
and so forth.
So for this, one for
the ActionBar, to theme
this one, what we're going to
do is the pre-existing style,
Theme.ActionBar is
part of the settings.
Because we want to have a
reusable ActionBar that we
can use in some other
different styles,
were actually going to
create our own style
called Cyngn.ActionBar.
And that's going to
allow us to cover
all the different
visual aspects of this.
So we'll be able to
change the background,
normally this is an
elevated ActionBar,
but you can set that
elevation value to zero,
and be able to
get that back down
on the same plane as the rest
of the settings, and so forth.
And you'll even see we make use
the common styles over here.
So that's for the
text right up here.
We actually have that
put in the Common,
so if I want to go into
like the Messaging app,
I can reference that
same style and I'll
know that my title
text is going to be
the same across every
single app that I'm theming.
What are some other
aspects that we can do?
Well, so we have all of
these icons right here.
So in this case, these are
actually vector drawables.
And we have those.
So each one of
these is going to be
a file that has all of the point
data that makes up the shape.
And again, you'll
see that we actually
have that common folder, again.
So we have a color.
So each one of these is
going to be using a color,
and we just reference
that in the common folder.
And again, so if you don't
like the way that green looks
anymore, you can
change it one time
and it's going to work
in all of those files.
You don't have to go through
30 different image vector
drawables, and be
like, I didn't like
that one, let me change
the hex code again, Nope.
Nice and easy and simple
with the common folder.
What are some other things?
Well, let's look at how
this is really composed.
So this entire screen is going
to be using this style called
Theme.SettingsBase.
There's a lot of
different things
here, so I know it looks
a little-- but, once you
start doing it a lot, it
actually starts to make sense.
So there's different
effects that you
can control like the
color background, right?
So I'm pointing that to a common
value, theme background, so
that way in every app,
I can make my background
color the same, because again,
I'm using that common folder.
I think you're going to
start to see the theme here.
Same thing with everything
else, like the theme edge.
So that's like when
you do the overscroll,
it does a little bit
of a color, that's
something you can also control.
It's pretty much every
aspect on the screen
is tweakable within a
theme, and you can really
create this custom look that
just really just is different.
So there's some
other stuff, too.
We've been talking about colors.
What about dimensions?
So you can do things
like the elevation.
So normally, in
the Lollipop theme,
all those categories are
actually lifted up as cards.
But for this one,
we've actually set
those against the background.
So we did that by changing
the elevation value.
There's other things
like padding and margins.
And you just tweak each
one just a little bit
and it allows you to
get this different look.
So we go from this
look, back to the stock,
and then back to what we did.
So you can see, it's
actually really different.
You can see we compressed
each of the line items.
We've got different colors.
All the spacing is different.
And it really gives you this
is a unique look that you're
able to achieve that if
you don't like it anymore,
you can turn it off.
And you don't have to, run
anything like a new ROM.
You don't have to
reset any settings.
It's easy as just
switching it off.
And so sometimes, there's going
to be some cross-pollination
when it comes to
elements that are
something you have to theme.
So in this instance, majority
of what's on the screen
is going to be within
the Settings app.
But there are a few things,
such as these switches
and that search icon
which aren't going
to be within the Settings app.
For something like that,
you're going to also
have to theme framework.
Because controls
like radio buttons,
check boxes, all originate
within the Android framework.
So you don't always get
to do just one overlay
to get the whole
entire look, sometimes
you're going to have to go
outside the box and say,
well I also have frameworks.
So you need to
consider how it's going
to look in all the different
ones that you're theming.
So that was just really
a big brief overview
of what goes into
creating a theme.
There's a ton of
styles and colors
and values that are out
there for you to tweak.
And it's really just about
diving in and seeing all those.
So, here's a couple things to
keep in mind, should you want
to get started and do this.
You want to try to reuse
your styles and colors
via that common folder.
Again, this is unique
to our theme engine,
and it's really
useful for making sure
that you don't have to do
more work in the future
when it comes to
tweaking things.
And this even allows you to
create variants of a theme.
Maybe you want to do a red
version, you really liked it.
So if you set
everything up correctly
using this common
folder, you can just
go in, tweak everything
within there,
and have like a different color
available, just like that.
Vector drawables.
These were recently introduced
with Lollipop API 21,
and they are fantastic.
If you're not familiar
with how Android
handles different
resolutions, it
creates these different buckets.
So you'll have
like drawable-hdpi.
That'll be for
like an HD screen.
You'll have drawable-xxhdpi.
That'll be for like a QHD.
And so what vector
drawables do, they
allow you to create
a single image
that you place in
drawable, and that's
going to scale up and down
based on your resolution needs,
allowing you to create
only one drawable,
and then have it look like
pixel-perfect on every device.
Otherwise, you're going to
have to sit there and make
each version, if you
want it to look good.
You could opt to go for a larger
one and have it scale down,
but this will give you
the most crisp results.
Framework styles.
Now, I did mention that you have
to do some things in framework.
Your controls, there's
no other way to do that.
But there are
styles in frameworks
such as like Theme.Material,
Theme.Material.Light--
you don't want to mess
with those, because those
can cause conflict in apps
that you're not specifically
theming.
So maybe you had Settings, which
was using Theme.Material.Light,
and you're like, oh, I want
this text to be white here,
and you go and change
it in the framework.
What will happen is, you may get
like a Reddit app that's also
using that, and
then you're going
to end up with white text
on a white background.
And that's not going to
look good for the user.
So you want to try to avoid
messing with the framework
styles, and handle
everything within an app.
You can still point to
those framework styles,
but you want to make sure that
you're doing most of your edits
within each one so
that way you don't
do any conflicts with apps
that you're not specifically
covering.
And if anybody's an app
developer out there,
you can help themers by not
putting your resources directly
within a layout.
So if you have a text view?
Don't just put a hex color right
there inside your layout file,
or point to like a
framework color that you
don't want them to change.
Point it into a colors XML,
or dimensions, or something
like that because otherwise,
themers can't touch it,
and that makes everybody sad.
So seriously, keep
it out of layouts.
But so yeah, so that's pretty
much a basic overview themes.
There's a lot to
dive into in and see.
And basically, the best way to
get started is just to dive in.
So we have a template
available on GitHub.
That's github.com/cyngn,
android packages teams template.
If you just search
Cyanogen theme template,
it'll come up in Google
search, first result.
But yeah, that's it.
I'm going to turn
it over to Clark,
who's going to tell you about
the next big thing coming
to CyanogenOS.
CLARK SCHEFF: Those of you that
are here, just want to say,
this is the first time that
we're showing this publicly,
so you guys are
privy to something
that hasn't been seen outside
Cyanogen, our offices itself.
So I'm really excited.
I'm humbled to be able to
be the one to present this,
because I love this feature.
It's really cool.
I hope you guys are
going to feel the same.
So let me just go
ahead and get started.
And let me start by saying,
there's one part of the OS
we saw that users interact
with all the time.
You see this screen, this
layout on a regular basis.
I don't have statistics,
but you're probably
doing it at least once an
hour, if not almost every five
minutes or so.
So that is the lock screen.
So what we've
proposing is a project
called Live Lock Screen.
Now we took a look at the
standard lock screen and said,
well what can we do with it?
Well, we need to
understand how it works,
and what's the problems
with it, and so forth.
So first thing, it's functional.
So that's not a downside.
That's a plus.
It's functional.
It serves a purpose.
You've got your time.
You've got notifications.
You've got stuff that's
important to you.
So it has that for it.
But it's static, right?
You turn it on, you see
the same screen every time.
You see your clock.
You see the same image.
With CyanogenMod, we
did allow the user
to change the lock
screen wallpaper.
But again, you're seeing that
same lock screen wallpaper
every time you turn your
screen on until you go in
and change that, so
it's always the same.
And to us, that's boring.
We're all about customization
and personalization,
and we want to bring
that tto the lock screen.
When you turn that
phone on, we want
you to at least enjoy that.
Even if it's for brief
moment, it should be fun,
it should be entertaining,
it should be lively.
So this is where we come up
with the Live Lock Screen.
It still has to be functional.
There's no doubt
about that, right?
We still have to provide
a lot of the information
that you see on your
normal lock screen.
We're accustomed to that.
But it doesn't have to
just stay at that point.
We want it to be dynamic.
It can be lively.
The idea is a lock
screen comes to life.
It becomes something
more than just
that screen that you see
when you turn your phone on.
And with this,
the customization,
it's really limited by the
theme designer's imagination.
We're trying to make this so
that it's as open as possible,
so that these guys can
create some awesome content.
And so every time you
yutn your screen on,
we want it to be fresh and fun.
And, depending on how they
implement their lock screens,
it can be different every
time that you turn it on.
It doesn't have
to stay the same.
So we're trying to go
from what's on the left
here to something
that's on the right.
Where we've got vivid colors,
we're going to have animations,
we've got time, we've got
stuff that we need to see,
but it's going to be in a way
that we enjoy looking at it.
When we're looking at
a Live Lock Screen,
we were looking at a lot
of different technologies.
How can we do this?
And we needed to keep in mind
who's our user, in this case,
for making a Live Lock Screen.
Well, that's theme designers.
That's guys that have
done stuff like this,
but they're not
necessarily coders.
They don't write
code, but they might
have done something
that's similar to coding--
or, it is coding, that is
Flash and ActionScript.
So a lot of the stuff we did,
we actually went with a WebView.
And we're using a lot of
frameworks and projects
that have been
standardized and provide
syntax similar to ActionScript.
So we want guys that are
doing maybe Flash animations
and stuff like that on webs to
be able to just jump right in.
The barrier to entry, we
wanted it to be very small.
The reason we went
with a WebView,
is because we can use WebGL.
We can use a canvas WebGL bat.
We can use all these existing
libraries that are Flash-like,
but not Flash,
because Flash is dead.
And just in case the
hardware doesn't support it,
this is also going
to use HTML5 canvas.
So it's a normal canvas, if
the device doesn't support it.
But if it does, it's going to be
hardware accelerated, and most
of our demos we're doing
60 frames per second.
And once I show it, it's pretty
awesome that we can do that.
One thing is, though, it
needs to be sandboxed.
It's a lock screen, right?
We don't want to open
up a security hole
where somebody can
access your information
or they can access the internet.
So even though it's
a WebView, there's
no internet permissions.
We've kept the permissions
down to the bare minimum
to facilitate what we need
to do for a lock screen
without compromising
the security.
So we were able to
achieve this because newer
versions of Android, they
introduced the JavaScript
interface API.
This basically allows
us to say, hey,
we want to allow these methods
to have access in JavaScript,
but nothing else.
So we can actually
lock this down
and say, give them the APIs
that we want them to have,
and just that.
There was a time in Android
where somebody could actually
cleverly do some
JavaScript and get
into any other class in Android
that they wanted access to,
and that was bad.
So that's where the JavaScript
interface came into place.
So we make use of that.
And we use it for things
like creating unlock methods.
So it's a lock screen, they're
going to have to unlock it,
but the way they unlock it is
still up to the theme designer.
So it could be swipe left
to right, draw a circle,
push a button.
Who knows what that is.
And so once the user
performs that action,
they can unlock it.
That could also unlock the
common apps like MMS, Browser,
Phone, your Camera,
things that you're
used to getting to you
from your lock screen.
In addition to that, we
provide some of the basic data
to the JavaScript side.
We have the time, the date.
Now, the time and
date they're formatted
in the locale for
the user, so we
return a string that's already
in the format that they need.
If you have a 24
hour clock, you're
going to see a 24 hour
clock on your screen,
even if it's the
Live Lock Screen.
And if you're in a different
locale, different language,
it's going to be
formatted in that format.
And then we have things
like battery level, battery
charging, so you can
get stats like that.
So the theme can show
different animations
based on battery level.
They can get things
like missed calls,
and so it lets you
code different text,
maybe a little bird flies and
says, you have missed tweets,
something like.
So because it's a
dynamic lock screen,
we need to have
data that's dynamic.
It needs to have some
way to be able to create
this different
contact on the fly
that changes with
time, date, weather.
Some of those
things, like I said,
there's battery state and level.
But there's also,
we provide weather.
So we can give the
JavaScript side,
here's the weather
formatted in text,
gives them the condition,
the city they're in.
But we also have some
constants to find.
We're using a Yahoo API
right now for the weather.
And so there's all these
different constants that
say what type of weather it is.
It's a thunderstorm,
it's snowing outside.
The theme could potentially
use that information
and change what they're
showing you on the screen.
So if it's thunderstorm
and lightning,
you could have some animation
of lightning going on,
and maybe you have to swipe
the lightning bolt away,
or something like that.
But I mean it provides a
lot more dynamic interface.
Time of day-- one thing we added
in, we actually found this gem.
Steve, our CTO, found this in
one of his projects he did.
There's this thing called
the Twilight Service.
Now, it's unfortunately not open
up to application developers.
But what this does, it takes
the user's geolocation and time
of day, and it can tell
us when the sunset is,
when tomorrow's sunrise
is, and stuff like that.
So we provided APIs that the
lock screen can use that stuff.
So you can know when the
sun's going to be setting,
so if you want to show a
night scene, you will know,
hey, it's past sunset, so I
can go ahead and show the night
scene.
If sun is rising, you
can show an animation.
Maybe the sun's starting
to come up on your screen
as you turn it on,
stuff like that.
We also have location.
It's generic.
It's just geolocation.
So if somebody wanted act
on a specific lat/long
to show something,
we provide that.
And in addition to that,
since it's your lock screen,
we want to show things like
missed calls, unread text
messages, unread emails.
So we have APIs for that.
They can't read those messages.
They can't read the
emails or anything.
We're just providing
those numbers
to let them know, hey, this is
how many unread emails this guy
has, so if you want to display
some UI with that, go ahead.
So one of things we
didn't want to do,
we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel.
We wanted to use things
that were already
out there in the industry
that have been proven
and they're very
popular, robust,
and that also fit the
criteria we wanted-- something
that was Flash or
ActionScript-esque so people
would be able to use it quickly.
Some of the technology we
ended up implementing-- we
have pixi.js, which is
a graphic frameworks.
It's supposed to be the
fastest kid in town,
so we went with that one.
There's a couple APIs
from this GreenSock
that provide animation.
So we have a TweenLight
library, and an EasePack that
provide smooth animations,
and it can also
change the rate of animations
to make them nice and smooth,
and provide a much
better visual experience.
And then because some lock
screens may want to do sounds,
we brought in this
Buzz! library,
which also facilitates
plain HTML sounds
without them having to
do the work of adding
an HTML5 audio element.
So it's all been abstracted
and real easy to use.
Real quick, I'm going to
go over some of these.
So pixi.js, like I said, they
say they have the fastest
kid in town, and so
far from the stuff
that we've been doing with
these Live Lock Screens,
we're getting 60
frames per second.
So these things are
really fast, and it's
being rendered on
OpenGL, so there's
a lot you could do on the GPU.
They provide multi-touch,
so all that's
available via the JavaScript.
So you can do touch events.
You'll be able to do single,
multi, whatever you want to do.
They also have a thing
called WebGL filters.
These are basically what
are known as GPU shaders.
So they can change
the way the images are
being drawn on the screen.
Maybe make something
look pixelated,
they have filters for that.
They have one that makes it
look like newspaper print.
So you can apply these
right on the fly,
with just a couple lines
of code and make it change.
They provide tinting
and blending.
So you can do all
the things you're
used to with graphics,
fading stuff in and out,
blending things together with
different colors, tinting them.
There's sprite sheet support.
So not everyone is
familiar with sprites,
but it's common
in 2D video games
where you could have a
whole set of animations
that define the different
cells for that animation.
So maybe a character running
across the screen, that's
all loaded in one image
called a sprite sheet,
and pixi allows you to
load that kind of stuff up.
It does it via this asset
loader, which does it
in the background,
so the lock screen
can do other code while
images are loading,
so they don't have
to waste cycles just
spinning around
waiting for stuff.
And of course, it supports text.
And text can be your own fonts,
system fonts, and bitmap fonts.
So sometimes you may not want
a font to just be flatter,
just colored, or maybe shaded--
you want more texture to it.
So you could provide
a whole bitmap
that's got all the
different letters in it,
and pixi will actually
draw your text
using that mapping of letters.
So like I said, we have a
couple APIs from GreenSocks.
We use TweenLite and
EasePack, and this
provides nice smooth
animations, similar to what
Android does, as
well, when you're
doing application development.
TweenLite, it basically
takes a couple properties
and it'll tween
them from an object.
So say you have an
object, xy, it'll
move it to this new position,
and you'd give it a time,
and it'll do that
transition for you.
All you do is say, hey,
I want you go from here
to here in this time, and
it performs the animation
without you having
to do any other work.
This works in
conjunction with EasePack
which actually provides ways for
that animation to be smoothed
out a lot better.
So instead of being
linear and just quickly
moving from one
spot to the other,
it can ramp up its speed, it
can bounce, it can stretch,
it can do stuff that makes the
animation a lot more lively,
and stuff that we're
used to in real life.
Because things don't just move
and then stop at the position,
they usually slow down.
So EasePack helps make that
easier for the theme designer.
And then Buzz!.
Like I said, that plays sounds.
It's a real easy API to use.
I was reviewing a
couple other ones,
and this one was like the
simplest out of all them.
It provides basic functionality.
You can load OGGs, WAVs, MP3s,
AACs, and as well as control
all the playing of it.
So you can loop it, you
can pause it, you can stop,
you can mute it, you can
fade in the volume, set it
to a specific value.
So it provides a
lot of the stuff
that you're going to need
for something like this,
and it's easy to use.
So with that said, this
is in early stages,
but I'm going to go
ahead and demo this.
This is the first time
we get to show this off.
This is really what Live Lock
Screens shines, because slides
can only say so much.
If the visor will
come back again.
OK.
So I've got a few little
Live Lock Screens here
that I've done.
When I was trying to do a
proof of concept for this,
I came up with a little demo.
I'm not Dave Kover.
I can't draw.
I'm an engineer.
I write code.
I can't do anything.
But I realize I
can do rectangles.
And I can do rectangles
really, really good.
And not only can I do
rectangles really good,
but I realized if I put these
rectangles in a certain way,
I can make it look like a city.
So I've got this little
cityscape lock screen,
and I can swipe on
it and it moves.
It's got like this little
pop-up book look and feel.
I can swipe and
it'll animate back
on when I let my finger go.
That's using TweenLite.
So this is a first demo.
So this is mine.
This looks really like
an engineer did it,
what can I say.
And then I can unlock, just
like a normal lock screen.
The next demo I came
up with-- pixi.js
actually had a demo of
using those WebGL filters
that I mentioned in
the tinting and stuff,
so I took their concept and
turned it into a Live Lock
Screen.
Their concept was
this little fish pond.
It was like a cartoonish
little fish pond.
I think I had that slide
of it for you guys.
I made it a lock screen.
And so we get this.
So now we have something that's
vibrant and actually animating.
So you see a lot
of motion on there,
but you still get some
information, right?
So I've still got my clock,
but it's fun to play with.
And as I swipe my finger down,
it'll actually distort more,
so you get that little
distortion effect going.
When I was using
their WebGL filters,
there was a displacement effect.
So I could play
around with that,
and tweak it, and then
when I unlock it'll go out.
So there's that one.
Now, we've been playing
with this internally.
A couple weeks ago,
we've actually put
this in our internal
dog food builds,
where we test our
stuff internally.
And a lot of the engineers, they
are getting excited about it,
and they're trying to
come up with stuff too.
And one of our
engineers, Dinesh, he
found one that was
actually a demo
by the guy the wrote pixi.js.
And it was done a
couple years ago,
so it was actually using an
older version of pixi.js,
but he ended up getting it
running on a Live Lock Screen.
And this one's
actually really fun.
So what we have is one
of those party poppers,
you know, where you
actually pull them apart
and you get confetti
blowing out.
And so he found
this, and then as I
move my finger you
can see it'll stretch,
it's got the rope effect
and stuff like that.
Now, when I swipe all
the way away-- man.
It's just one of those
things that it's fun.
You're interacting
with your phone,
you might as well
have some fun with it
since that's the part you're
going to see every day.
So the last demo is a
little bit of a two-parter.
This is something that I cooked
up a couple weekends ago.
So this is a social media,
where we're playing around
with maybe providing a way,
API to get social media images
and stuff like that
onto your lock screen.
So this demo's actually
going to use Instagram.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to type in a hashtag,
and I'm going to go-- I think
it's on my tag, BABBQ15.
So I'm going to enter BABBQ15.
I'm going to say Fetch.
Hopefully, my
internet's working.
Now I'm going to switch over
to the Social Media Gallery
lock screen.
And if all goes well--
hey, is that you?
No, OK.
I thought that was Ray.
So as we go, it
pulls in the most
20 recent hashtags for that
particular tag that I entered,
and you'll be able to see
those images actually flashing.
And I can swipe
this up, let it go.
There's that bounce, so that's
using those animations again.
This one's still early.
We're still playing
with this one.
But it shows the potential of
how you can have a lock screen.
So now, not only do
you have animations,
but you have different
backgrounds every time
you turn your screen on, and it
can change throughout the day.
Hey, I know that guy.
Awesome.
I do believe the demo gods
are with us this time.
That concludes our presentation.
We have some time, so if anybody
has any questions, feel free.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]